على كل حال ينضم الينا من رام الله الخبير
والمحلل العسكري اللواء واصف عريقات اهلا
بك معنا ماذا يعني ان يتوجه نتنياهو
لجنوده ويقول لهم لديكم تفويض بمواصله
القتال وليس بوقف اطلاق
النار يعني بالتاكيد نتنياهو مخادع
نتنياهو كاذب نتنياهو يعرف الحقيقه يعني
هو يريد ان يحمل فشل الجيش الاسرائيلي
للجنود الاسرائيليين حقيقه حينما حينما
يعني يفشل الجيش في تحقيق مهامه واهدافه
انا
اعتقد الهزيمه الكبرى تكون لمن خطط له لمن
ارسله للقتال وهو يعرف وهو يعرف ان هذا
الجيش غير قادر على تحقيق اهدافه وحينما
نتحدث عن 72 يوم وهناك اربع فرق عسكريه من
نخبه النخبه وما زالت الاشتباكات تدور في
المناطق الاولى من منذ الحرب البريه وهي
بيت لاهيه وبيت حانون وجباليا وحتى الان
لم يستطيعوا ولم يتمكنوا من تحقيق سيطره
على متر واحد من الارض هناك تسلل صحيح
هناك كر وفر للدبابات والاليات صحيح هناك
تحرك توغل صحيح ولكن كل هذا في ظل اسناد
مدفعي وفي ظل اسناد جوي حينما يفقد
الاسناد الجوي ويفقد الاسناد المدفعي لا
يستطيع الجندي الاسرائيلي ان يتحرك كما
يتحرك اليوم اليوم حينما يتضايق الجندي
الاسرائيلي ينسحب من مواقعه ويترك المجال
للطائره ومدفعيه ان تحل محله ما هي نق لكن
اذا ما اراد الضعف سيد واصف التي عينتها ل
عينتها للجيش الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بخوضه
للمعارك داخل المدن
والاحياء يعني اولا الجيش
الاسرائيلي مدرب على الحرب الكلاسيكيه
والنظام بمعنى ان هناك سلاح جو يقصف قصف
تدميري وتمهيدي للمنطقه التي يتقدم فيها
الجندي الاسرائيلي على الارض ويتقدم على
ارض بسياسه الارض المحروقه يعني ما لا
يوجد هناك اي مقاومه وحينها يسجل الصار
الان في حال المقاومه لا الجندي
الاسرائيلي عليه ان يواجه المقاومه وجها
لوجه سلاح لسلاح وهنا المعركه ليست معركه
سلاح بقدر ما هي معركه ايرادات معركه
معنويات معركه روح قتاليه وهذه يفقدها
الجندي الاسرائيلي الجندي الاسرائيلي غير
مؤهل وغير مدرب على الحرب في القتال
المبنيه رغم انه كان هناك تدريبات لهم
وكان هناك سيناريوهات حاكت قتال المناطق
المبنيه وبنوا بنوا مدينه تشابه مدينه غزه
في صحراء النقب وتدربوا عليها ولكن
التدريب شيء وحينما يتم المواجهه
الميدانيه مع المقاومين شيء اخر المقاوم
الفلسطيني اعتقد يعني لديه من الب رساله
والشجاعه مما يدخل الرعب في قلوب
الاسرائيليين الجندي الاسرائيلي فاقد
للمعنويات هو جاء الى قطاع غزه بروح
الهزيمه والانكسار من يوم
17 وحينما التقى وجها لوجه مع المقاومين
الفلسطينيين ويشاهد ويشاهد بطولات هؤلاء
بالصوت والصوره كيف ينقضوا على الدبابات
ويشتبك من مسافه صفر وكيف ح وصلت بالمس قب
قبل خوضنا في الحديث عن نقاط القوه لدى
المقاومين
غزه فقيد واصف ننوه الى هذه الصور
المباشره التي نتابعها الان من معبر رفح
والتي تظهر
تسلم عدد او توزيع مساعدات اغاث على
النازحين فاذا في معبر
رفح اذا هذه صور مباشره تاتينا من معبر
رفح تظهر توزيع مساعدات اغاث ل
النازحين هناك اعود اليك مجددا سيد واصف
بالحديث عن التكتيكات التي تتبعها
المقاومه ما نقاط القوه
التي تتابعها
وفق ما تحققه المقاومه بكل فصائلها في
الميدان يعني اولا التنسيق والتعاون بين
كافه الفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه لا تقوض
حرب جيوش بمعنى مواقع دفاعيه ثابته ا تخوض
معركه مجموعات صغيره متحركه
لديها اسلحه متنوعه تتناسب والاشتباك مع
الجنود وتتناسب مع الاشتباك مع الدبابات
والاليات اي تقوم تقوم بالاستطلاع وجمع
المعلومات هي غير منظوره للعدو الاسرائيلي
العدو الاسرائيلي منظور لها هي تتحكم
بالجغرافيا بطبيعه الارض وخاصه بعد
تدميرها من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي اي يعني
نرا نشاهد ان هذه المجموعات تتحرك من بين
من تحت الانقاظ ومن بين الحفر وتستطيع ان
تتحكم ب مجريات الامور وتستطلع اهدافها
وتنصب الكمائن
وتشتبك من مسافه صفر وهذا طبعا يعني اعجاز
عسكري حقيقه وبساله وشجاعه منقطعه النظير
وهي التي تدخل الرعب في قلوب وعقول الجنود
الاسرائيليين لذلك هذا يضعف من امكانياتهم
على المواجهه ويقلل من قدرتهم على القتال
واكبر دليل على ذلك ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه يعني بالصوت والصوره تظهر كيف
يقوم المقاتلين الابطال بالانقضاض على
المواقع وخاصه تلك المواقع في العمق وهي
كما جرى في حجر ديك وهذه انا بتقديري يعني
اكثر من رساله رساله للجنود رساله للضباط
رساله للقياده السياسيه ورساله للقياده
العسكريه التي تخطط لمسافات او
لمساحات بعيده واوقات طويله لتقول لها انه
لا فائده من وجود الجيش الاسرائيلي في
قطاع غزه لانه لن يحقق سبقا كانت تقديرات
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان هذه الحرب ستحسم في
غضون ايام الان تقديرات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن
ان حسم المعركه ضد كتائب القسام قد يحتاج
اشهر ما الذي نفهمه من هذا السياق يعني
يعني قيا قياسا بما يجري على الارض الان
بعد 72 ساعه لا يزال الجيش الاسرائيلي
يناور في مساحه 30 الى 40% فقط تقصد 72
يوما سيد
واصف 72 يوما اه 72 72 يوم والجيش
الاسرائيلي لا لا يزال يناور في في 30%
فقط من مساحه قطاع غزه هذا يعني اذا اذا
اراد ان يتمدد على 100% من قطع غزه هذا
يحتاج الى ثلاث او واربع اضعاف القوات
الاسرائيليه موجود الان 100000 جندي
اسرائيلي اذا هو بحاجه الى 300,000 او
400,000 جندي اسرائيلي هل يوجد هل هناك
امكانيه لزج 400,000 جندي اسرائيلي وكل
الجيش الاسرائيلي 600,000 يعني هناك هناك
اكثر من 150 الى 200000 موزعين بالشمال في
مواجهه الجبهه اللبنانيه وهناك 100,000 في
الضفه الغربيه اذا لن يتبقى جنود تكفي على
الارض هذا اذا ما ما يعني اذا ما حسبنا
ايضا الخسائر هل هل هناك من يتحمل الخسائر
اليوميه التي تتراوح ما بين 10 الى 15
جندي بين قتيل وجريح وبين 10 الى 15 دبابه
واليه انا اعتقد يعني حتى الان خرجت من
العمل ما يعادل لواء مشا وما يعادل دبابات
واليات فرقه فرقه عسكريه هل يستطيع الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يستمر لاشهر او لاكثر من
اشهر على هذا الحال انا بتقديري من الصعب
على نتن و على القياده العسكريه بغض النظر
عما يتحدثون عنهم طبعا لا يستطيعوا ان
يقولوا لجبه تهم الداخليه ولا لحلفائه
الامريكان انهم فشلوا او انهم هزموا هم
يسابقون الزمن الان من يقول ان نحون صوره
نصر ام ان نتنياهو يريد كسب الوقت لانه
متخوف على مستقبله السياسي وهنا اسالك هل
تتوقع ان تتخذ القياده العسكريه ربما
قرارات
بعيده عن موافقه نتنياهو فيما يتعلق بهذه
الحرب خاصه ان هناك مؤشرات يبدو على شرخ
بين
الطرفين يعني اختي العزيزه اذا ما استمر
الجيش الاسرائيلي على هذا الحال لفتره
اطول وهناك خسائر كبيره في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي دون ان يكون هناك تحقيق اهداف
عسكريه على الارض انا بتقديري لن يستطيع
لا وزير الحرب ولا رئيس هيئ الاركان هالفي
ان اي يستمر في هذا العدوان من سيتحمل
المسؤوليه نتنياهو صحيح يريد اطاله امد
القتال لانه يريد ان يتهرب لانه يعرف
تماما وقف الحرب يعني هو ذهاب الى السجن
والى القضاء لذلك وحتى وحتى وزير الحرب
جلنت ورئيس هيئه الاركان هاليفي الذين
اعلنوا بالامس انهم يتحملون مسؤوليه ما
جرى لقتل الثلاث جنود الاسرى هذا من جانب
ومن جانب اخر يوم 17 ايضا عم
الاقص هم ايضا مسؤولين اذا هم مجموعتهم
مسؤولين امام القضاء لذلك هم يريدون اطاله
امد القتال